too many people in the world
still live in poverty too many children
don't go to school
too many infants die before their fifth
birthdays
too many families don't have enough food
to eat or access to energy
the global environment is changing and
in order to meet the challenges of the
future
the eu needs to equip itself with a more
modern development policy
we can no longer be everywhere and do
everything the way we deliver aid has to
change
the agenda for change is about inspiring
change in our partner countries
it outlines what future eu development
policy should look like
by concentrating on two main priorities
priority number one is supporting
genuine political and democratic reforms
and good governance because this will
put citizens at the heart of development
priority number two is about stimulating
inclusive and sustainable growth
that will create jobs for people because
growth and jobs are the engine of human
development
we will work in different ways with
countries which are progressing well
we will focus our aid in those countries
which need it most
including fragile states and where we
can have the most impact
we will improve the way we work together
with other donors
especially with our member states we
will simplify our programming process
responding to our partners needs thus
avoiding both duplication
and gaps we will concentrate on a
maximum of three sectors per country
we will use innovative financial
instruments such as blending loans and
grants
and bring in the private sector as a
partner for development
we will also strive to ensure that all
eu policies are coherent
and benefit development so we are
changing the way we deliver eu aid
so as to inspire change in our partner
countries
together we will contribute to
eliminating poverty and improve
lives the world over
the agenda for change an agenda for the
future
you